Musique douce
-Il faut trouver quelque chose
pour le stage.
-Dans les métiers,
je vois
"technicien pour ordinateur",
en gros,
développeur mobile,
je sais pas exactement
ce que c'est,
mais je suis pas sûr
qu'en informatique,
il y a des stages.
-Si.
-D'où t'est venue l'idée
de faire
pour moi, un métier
dans l'informatique ?
-Alors, ça,
c'est le bulletin
de Mohamed.
-OK.
-Quand un bulletin
qui t'ouvre toutes les portes,
du coup,
tu t'ouvres les portes,
un petit peu,
pour aller là où tu veux aller.
D'accord ?
Musique douce électro
...
-Vous allez à Château ?
-Oui.
Il faut un niveau de ouf.
-Je pense à russe,
histoire-géographie, géopolitique
et euh... sciences politiques.
...
Applaudissements
-Troisième, Riwan.
On va peaufiner sa culture
avec "Astérix chez les Pictes".
Félicitations
à tous ces lauréats.
-Vous êtes fan de mangas ?
-Mangas, BDs...
-Bravo !
On est fiers de vous,
bravo !
-Je montre pas
ce que je ressens
parce que les autres
pourraient me juger.
J'ai appris à garder
ma personnalité à moi
pour moi et à montrer
ce que je veux montrer
aux autres.
J'aimerais
être vraiment invisible.
Je m'en vais.
Je pars en Angleterre
pendant un an.
-Il faut vider les placards
de cette cuisine.
-Tes amis vont te manquer ou pas ?
-Oui, mais...
Enfin, c'est pas grave.
C'est sûr, je vais me sentir seule.
-Moi d'abord.
-Je sais, toi d'abord.
-En route, Coline. Tu y arrives ?
-Euh, ouais.
-A Manchester !
-Des fois,
ils se moquent de moi.
C'est des moqueries
sur mon physique
ou sur mon style, etc.
-D'accord.
-Ils rigolent
en me regardant mal, etc.
-Cette année,
ça a été très compliqué.
L'année prochaine,
je vais changer
de collège.
Je quitte Les Gayeulles
et je vais
dans le collège privé,
derrière.
J'espère que c'est pour le mieux,
mais bon, voilà.
Piano doux
...
-Lilou, Riwan, Maël, Coline,
Mohamed.
Ils sont nés en 2008.
Leurs chemins se sont croisés
en classe de 6e à Rennes.
Depuis, nous les suivons
dans leur vie sur une décennie,
avec des questions :
comment grandit-on
dans les années 2020 ?
Quels seront leurs parcours ?
Qui seront-ils demain ?
Les réponses se dessinent
avec le temps
à travers cette série
qu'il est impossible
d'écrire à l'avance.
Voici quelques moments de vie
capturés dans l'année,
celle de leurs 14 ans.
Musique émouvante
...
Musique rock
-J'aurais pu faire genre,
je mange une salade de fruits
ou un truc comme ça.
...
C'est un peu difficile
au niveau
santé mentale.
Je continue à grandir,
j'ai encore beaucoup
de questions existentielles
sur moi-même.
J'ai toujours des crises d'angoisse.
C'est un peu difficile.
Y a des bons moments,
y a des mauvais moments,
mais c'est moins sombre.
Je remonte la pente.
-Va te préparer
parce qu'il est 07h06.
-Ca va.
...
-Je me maquille parce que,
genre, ça me détend.
...
Je fais le maquillage
qui va
avec mes vêtements.
Là, j'ai un pull bleu,
je fais un maquillage bleu, quoi.
...
Après, moi, ça m'a l'air bien,
mais bon...
Ouais, ça m'a l'air bien.
...
Lui, il va m'attendre ici.
-Bonne journée, bisous !
-Bonne journée !
Les Gayeulles,
ça a vraiment été
un endroit
où je venais la boule au ventre.
Je m'enfermais aux toilettes
pour avoir aucune interaction.
Musique douce
Quand tu te fais harceler,
en plus,
en 4e, c'est la période
où tu te construis, tu grandis...
En plus,
t'as un mal-être présent,
bah, c'est très difficile.
...
Sur ce plan-là, je me sens mieux,
je pense que la classe,
c'est la meilleure classe
que j'ai eue au collège.
...
J'avais hyper peur,
en tout début d'année,
d'avoir une mauvaise classe,
Je me disais :
"Imagine, c'est encore pire"
Mais, moi, j'ai eu
une classe vraiment bien.
Je les aime tous.
-Bonjour.
-J'ai deux meilleurs amis,
en ce moment.
Yves ! Yves ! Yves,
Yves, Yves, Yves...
T'as fait le truc sur Blai...
Blaise... Blaise Pascal ?
C'est pour vendredi, il faut faire
un traitement de texte.
-Au pire, je fais ça aujourd'hui...
-Ca prend pas beaucoup de temps.
Ils sont un peu comme moi.
Genre, ce sont pas
des gens populaires,
mais c'est pas des gens non plus
au fond du fond, quoi.
On a un peu le même statut social,
quoi.
...
-C'est la deuxième crise
de la guerre froide qu'on va
examiner aujourd'hui.
-J'ai l'impression
qu'ils notent
beaucoup plus dur
qu'aux Gayeulles.
Y a plus de contrôles,
j'ai remarqué.
Ils préparent un niveau très...
Très élevé.
-Le mur, il va durer
jusqu'à sa chute
en 1989.
-"Le 6 octobre 1989,
Gorbatchev
"arrive à Berlin Est."
-C'est la réunification
de l'Allemagne.
-Si deux droites...
-Il y a plus de discipline.
-...parallèles.
-On peut beaucoup plus facilement
avoir des heures de colle,
des sanctions.
-Deux droites sécantes,
elles déterminent,
deux triangles
dont les longueurs des côtés
sont proportionnelles.
-Par exemple,
si y a une baston,
les deux ont des heures de colle
pendant des semaines, y a
des rendez-vous avec leurs parents.
Alors qu'aux Gayeulles, ils voient
juste la CPE et après,
ils ont rien
et après ils recommencent, après.
Musique rock
...
-Y a des gens,
c'est des zizis.
Ce genre de personnes,
c'est ré-pu-gnant.
-Ah oui !
-Oh là là, mon Dieu.
-Ah ouais !
-Aux Gayeulles, les garçons sont
maintenant les doyens du collège.
Ils abordent les sujets d'actualité
avec plus de maturité.
...
-Terme générique :
dessin de presse.
A l'intérieur
du dessin de presse,
la caricature.
-C'est tellement vrai.
-Quels sont
les thèmes abordés ?
-Bah politique...
-Oui !
-L'actualité.
-Oui, encore.
-Euh, économie...
-Oui.
Vous avez compris le principe ?
La consigne est la suivante.
Chacun va trouver
une illustration
sur cette thématique :
vous m'illustrez
un préjugé
sur les jeunes.
-Alors là, on va s'éclater.
-Des préjugés sur la jeunesse,
il y en a partout.
Je ne veux pas un dessin commun
à deux élèves.
...
Ils ricanent.
Vous avez encore 2-3 minutes.
...
Bien, stop.
Merci.
Brouhaha de la classe
L'adolescent,
il est sale.
Sa chambre est une porcherie.
Les mouches me disent
que c'est une odeur
à tomber par terre.
Il est scotché à son écran.
C'est bien, c'est réussi.
-Je vous confie
une petite caméra thermique,
vous allez au niveau du hall
du bâtiment.
-Les gars,
les gars !
Je vous propose
qu'on fasse
une photo vue d'ensemble
des deux portes du hall.
-Ils travaillent même
sur les préoccupations
très concrètes du moment.
-OK.
Là, c'est pareil.
-Mitraille.
-Là.
On voit juste là, la chaleur,
elle est en train de s'échapper,
donc, OK, euh...
Là, voilà.
Vas-y. Euh...
-Qu'est-ce qu'on voit,
d'ailleurs, là ?
-C'est bon, on a tout ce qu'il faut,
il a dit, le prof.
Let's go !
-Alors...
On va faire un petit retour
rapide.
Est-ce que vous pouvez
les gars, nous expliquer
ce qu'on voit, là ?
-On peut voir
que le froid rentre
dans le bâtiment
à travers cette porte.
-Si on fait ça chez vous ?
Mohamed ?
-Oh, pire.
Ca laisse tout passer...
-Tout ?
-Ouais.
-Vous le sentez ?
-Oui.
-Riwan, c'est pas flagrant
chez vous ?
-L'appartement, il est vieux,
donc je pense que...
Si, quand même, un peu.
-Dans le contexte actuel,
ça veut dire quoi ?
Si vous suivez un peu
les actualités en ce moment...
-C'est problématique.
-C'est problématique,
pourquoi ?
-Vu que le prix de l'énergie
coûte de plus en plus cher.
-Ouais,
donc c'est de l'énergie perdue.
Je vous souhaite une bonne journée.
-MERCI.
Brouhaha
Musique pop douce
...
-A 600 kilomètres au nord
de la salle de techno
se trouve
la ville de Manchester.
...
Cette année,
Coline est donc mancunienne.
A 14 ans,
600 kilomètres
loin de ses amis,
ça change la vie.
...
-A Rennes, des fois,
quand je me baladais
dans la rue,
j'entendais des bribes
de discussion entre les gens,
alors que là, la plupart du temps,
quand je sors,
je suis toute seule.
...
Le collège,
c'est pas simple.
On est moins de 100 filles
pour plus de 200 garçons.
Tout le monde est dispersé
dans les cours.
C'est encore plus difficile
de créer des liens.
Il y a pas un groupe classe.
C'est pas des gens
avec qui je ressens l'envie
de rester amis avec eux
toute ma vie.
-Coline au collège,
il faudra se l'imaginer.
La caméra n'a pas pu
dépasser les grillages
et les slogans bienveillants.
...
La maison de Coline
est plus accueillante.
*Musique pop dynamique
Embarquée par les parents
dans une année de césure,
Coline est arrivée
il y a trois mois...
-Merci, c'est gentil.
-Mince, mon tee-shirt...
-...pas vraiment convaincue.
*Musique douce
-J'ai trop de devoirs
en maths.
-Qu'est-ce que tu t'es dit
en arrivant ?
Tu as fait
"Waouh, un an ici" ?
-Euh...
Elle souffle.
-Je me suis dit :
"Putain, ça va être long."
Et voilà.
-Et là, tu te dis quoi ?
-"Putain, il reste encore 6 mois."
Elle rit.
Musique mélancolique
*Propos en anglais
...
*...
-Ca veut dire quoi,
"Oh my godness" ?
-C'est "Oh là là",
"Bonté divine",
quelque chose comme ça.
-OK.
-Je crois.
C'est une expression.
-La compréhension...
Ca fait bizarre.
Je comprends pas tout.
C'est la barrière de la langue.
...
*...
L'expression orale, ça bloque.
J'ai du mal à m'exprimer.
J'ai peur de faire des phrases
qui ressemblent à rien,
qui veulent rien dire,
donc je ne dis rien.
-Et tu passes des journées entières
à ne parler à personne ?
-Oui.
...
-Ta semaine
s'est bien passée ?
-L'anglais, c'est chiant.
C'est trop, trop chiant.
-C'est vrai que l'intégration
est plus difficile
et plus lente
que ce qu'on imaginait.
On est plus isolés
que ce qu'on pensait.
Du coup, au collège,
ça se passe bien quand même ?
-Ca passe. Ca passe.
C'est pas, je me lève le matin
et je me dis :
"Oh, je vais y aller,
ça va être trop bien !"
Je me dis : "Putain, c'est chiant,
je veux rester au fond de mon lit."
C'est bon ?
-Ca te paraît comment ?
-Ca me paraît bien.
Hop, on mange.
-Ses contacts amicaux,
ils sont en France...
et c'est aussi pour ça
que c'est difficile, je pense.
-Je dois avancer
là-dedans.
-Ca, c'est ton cours ?
C'est le truc que t'as...
-Oui, c'est tout
depuis le début.
Je réponds juste...
C'est bon, c'est bon,
c'est bon, c'est bon.
-Ca, tu l'as lu ou pas ?
-Euh...
-Je veux bien t'aider,
mais tu laisses ton téléphone.
Merci.
T'as un endroit
où ça parle
des modes d'action
des globules blancs ?
-Euh... C'est...
là.
-A mon avis, c'est ici.
C'est jamais facile
de n'échanger que par SMS
ou que par téléphone,
de ne pas être présent.
*Sonnerie
De savoir qu'il se passe des choses,
alors qu'elle est pas là,
c'est pas simple.
On en est conscients.
Malheureusement,
on peut pas faire grand-chose.
Donc, les modes d'action
des globules blancs
contre les pathogènes.
Il en faut trois.
*Sonnerie
-Oui...
Oups.
-Euh...
*...
Il y a les...
Là, ça va être relou, là.
-Ouais, je sais.
Je... Je...
Je dis que je peux pas.
-Hm.
-Euh...
-Il y a 3 mois,
tu te disais :
"Ils vont pas me manquer..."
-Alors, en fait, non.
Elle rit.
Non, en fait, non.
Je pense qu'ils me manquent plus
que j'imaginais.
Musique éthérée
Je passais quand même la moitié
de ma journée avec eux.
De 8h à 17h,
j'étais avec eux au collège.
12, 13 et 14.
-Ouais, t'en as mis
un peu trop, là.
-J'en ai mis trop
pour Timothée.
Timothée, j'allais avec lui
tous les jours au collège,
toujours ensemble.
Je veux
plein de bougies !
Tu les vois autant que ta famille.
Ca devient ta famille.
Je pense que tout le monde
a besoin de gens
avec qui partager
des trucs,
parler, faire des conneries...
des trucs comme ça, quoi.
*-Encore une bougie de soufflée
Encore une année passée-é-é-é
-Mais ça, là,
tu l'as pas ici ?
-Non...
tout simplement parce que
je n'ai pas d'amis au collège.
C'est pas facile.
Ils applaudissent et crient de joie.
-Ils te manquent beaucoup, là ?
...
Chahut d'enfants
-Bonjour à tous. D'habitude,
c'est une séance, effectivement,
sur la vie de classe.
Mais là,
je dois vous préparer
à vos trois jours de stage.
Il y a Timothée qui m'écoute pas.
Hein, Timothée ?
T'es d'accord avec moi ?
Donc, le but est,
quand même, de montrer
que vous pouvez donner
une bonne image.
Je vais vous donner
cette feuille-là.
Vous allez, en fait,
répondre aux questions.
D'accord ?
-Alors... Allons-y.
J'arrive en avance ?
-Pas trop.
Musique douce
-"Dois-je être ponctuel ?"
Oui !
C'est quoi,
cette question ?
Ils ricanent.
J'avais pas besoin
de questions comme ça.
"En cas de retard, que faire ?"
-Appeler.
Prévenir.
-Appeler l'entreprise.
"Dois-je faire attention...
-"A MON VOCABULAIRE
PENDANT TOUTE LA DUREE DU STAGE,
"MEME EN PAUSE ?"
-Bien sûr !
-Maintenant,
vous devez vous préparer,
vous présenter.
Il y a quelqu'un
qui fait le tuteur
ou l'entrepreneur,
et l'autre personne se présente.
C'est la première impression
qu'on a,
la première rencontre
avec son tuteur.
Je trouve ça important.
C'est bon ? C'est parti.
On frappe.
-Entrez.
Musique malicieuse
Entrez !
Bon, bah il est en retard...
...
Entrez !
-Allez !
Ils rient.
-On la refait.
-Et...
Il éclate de rire.
...
-Arrête de rigoler
dès que tu dis ce que tu vas faire.
...
N'importe quoi.
-Non !
-C'est complexe.
Je sais que c'est complexe.
-Bonjour, monsieur.
-Bonjour.
Vous êtes stagiaire de 3e ?
-Oui.
-Vous teniez à être avec moi
pendant les deux jours suivants.
Je m'appelle Bruno Alvarez,
chef de rédaction
pour le journal.
Alors, est-ce que tu sais
ce que tu vas faire ici
pendant les deux jours ?
-Un stage d'observation.
Je vais observer la vie
du journal pendant deux jours.
-Hmm.
Tu sais pourquoi
tu as choisi Ouest-France ?
-Tout d'abord, parce que c'est
le principal journal de la région.
Et puis, même si
je ne suis pas sûr
de faire journaliste comme métier,
c'est une voie
qui m'intéresse.
-Très bien, on va pouvoir commencer.
-Là, c'est mieux.
"Pourquoi Ouest-France ?"
"C'est le journal principal..."
Montre que tu connais. Tu le lis ?
-Bien sûr.
-Alors, tu dis :
"Oui, je lis Ouest-France,
"ça m'intéresse,
j'aime suivre l'actualité..."
T'es pas passionné
de journalisme non plus,
mais montre que tu t'y connais,
que tu suis l'actualité,
que ça t'intéresse
de faire ça.
Musique dynamique
...
-Ce matin,
Maël file peut-être
vers sa future vie.
Alors, t'es stressé ?
-Non, ça va.
Ca va être super,
très intéressant.
...
C'est sa première journée
métro-boulot-dodo.
-Faut pas
que ce soit non plus
la seule chose importante
dans la vie,
le boulot.
Faut que ce soit une passion.
Si tu travailles juste
pour gagner de l'argent,
ça n'a aucun intérêt.
*-Station Saint-Germain.
-Si tu prends pas de plaisir
à aller au travail,
que tu te lèves le matin,
tu vas au travail,
tu rentres le soir,
tu manges, tu dors,
que tu retournes au travail,
que tu t'amuses pas
et que ça te plaît pas,
ça n'a aucun intérêt.
...
Bonjour.
-Bonjour !
Bienvenue. Je suis Bruno Alvarez,
je suis le chef de la rédaction ici.
C'est le plateau
de la rédaction.
Donc voilà.
Bah écoute, bienvenue.
Je vais te donner
un journal,
je ne sais pas
si t'as pu le lire ce matin.
-J'ai juste lu...
le...
La première page
et le début de...
"Monde-France".
-D'accord.
On accueille aujourd'hui Maël,
qui est en 3e,
et donc en stage d'observation.
-Journaliste
parmi les journalistes,
Maël apprend
les bases du métier.
D'abord, l'observation.
-La ville décide de passer
le centre-ville
en zone à trafic limité.
-On a une affaire
en cours
qui est intéressante,
à la sûreté départementale.
-C'est 6 mois d'enquête
sur les nouveaux modes
de livraison de drogue,
un genre d'"Ubershit".
Ils rient.
-OK, ça marche.
On en reste là ?
Tu vois, la suite de la réunion
à laquelle t'as assisté ce matin,
quand on a fait la conférence
de rédaction avec l'équipe...
Ensuite, j'ai cet outil,
le paginateur.
En dessous,
je peux écrire mon texte.
-Puis, l'interview.
-Vous, vous avez commencé
par être simplement journaliste ?
-J'ai fait la fac, puis...
les deux écoles de journalisme.
-D'accord.
-J'ai fait des stages pratiques,
et puis après,
j'ai fait des piges,
jusqu'à être embauché
par le journal.
-D'accord.
-J'ai d'abord été
prof de philo.
-Donc, vous avez pas fait
d'école particulière...
-Non, j'ai pas fait
de grande école de journalisme.
-Et vous ?
-C'est à mon tour ?
Dès le lycée,
je voulais faire ça.
Au tout début, je voulais être
chroniqueuse musicale.
-Des notes
pour le rapport de stage...
-On essaie de prendre le pouls,
un petit peu, de ce qu'on dit...
-...et évidemment,
le terrain...
-C'est où, la conférence de presse ?
-C'est à l'Arvor, le cinéma.
-...et la curiosité
qui va avec.
-Vous avez fait
une école particulière ?
-Non, l'université.
J'ai fait communication,
de la linguistique, aussi.
...
-Il dure combien de temps,
le festival ?
-Une semaine.
-Ravi d'accueillir
ce festival
pour sa 38e édition.
Merci à vous
et bon festival.
-En fait, dans le journal,
la une, c'est pas toujours
le même journaliste
qui la fait ?
-Non, ça dépend de l'actualité.
-D'accord.
-Maël, je vais t'expliquer
un petit peu
mon travail.
L'article que j'ai ici,
il m'arrive brut,
en fait.
Je peux refaire
des modifications dedans.
Alors, "A Villejean,
ils retapent un bus
"d'un autre âge pour sauvegarder
la mémoire du quartier."
Tu vois qu'il y a un petit souci,
le titre est trop long.
Comme j'ai peu d'espace,
je vais gagner de la place
comme ça.
T'imaginais que c'était comme ça,
faire un journal ?
-Ah non, je pensais pas.
-Non ?
Tu veux être journaliste ?
-C'est une des voies
qui m'intéresse.
-C'est vraiment un plus
si tu peux déjà...
Il y a souvent des journaux
dans les lycées,
écrits par des lycéens.
-Oui.
Après, si vraiment
tu continues là-dedans,
quand tu postules dans des écoles
pour devenir journaliste,
ils regardent beaucoup si t'as déjà
un petit peu d'expérience.
-D'accord. Merci beaucoup.
-De rien.
-La fin de l'hiver
n'est plus si loin,
le brevet des collèges non plus.
L'oral blanc...
-Installez-vous.
-...encore moins.
-Je rappelle
que demain, vous présentez
votre rapport de stage.
On va faire
un petit exercice de relaxation,
de visualisation,
d'anticipation,
pour essayer de mettre
le stress à distance.
Alors,
vous êtes tous assis...
posément sur votre chaise.
Vous êtes enracinés par terre,
tranquillement.
Vous vous isolez de tout le reste,
sauf de ma voix.
Vous allez fermer les yeux.
Et là, vous allez tranquillement
adopter une respiration calme.
Donc je vais
vous reconstituer le déroulement
de votre séance de demain.
Vous vous voyez en train de faire
tout ce que je vous dis.
Musique intrigante
Ce soir,
je prépare mes affaires.
Le matin de l'épreuve,
vous vous levez à l'heure
qui vous permet de vous préparer
sans vous stresser.
Vous arrivez au collège
avec un peu d'avance,
vous êtes en sécurité
dans ces lieux.
Tout va bien.
-3B.
-Euh... 3B...
Où est-ce que t'es ? Là !
Bah, bienvenue !
-Merci.
-Alors, c'est ton premier examen ?
-Euh, ouais.
-Ca fait quoi ?
-C'est stressant.
-Tu arrives à savoir pourquoi ?
-Non. Je sais pas.
C'est ça, le pire.
C'est une évaluation
comme une autre, en fait.
C'est ça le truc à se dire,
mais c'est stressant encore plus.
Je ne sais pas pourquoi.
-Vous allez arriver
dans la salle qui est inscrite
sur votre convocation.
Vous vous y présentez.
Vous êtes en confiance,
vous respirez si jamais
vous vous sentez
un peu stressé.
Vous restez à l'extérieur,
vous attendez que le juré
vous fasse entrer.
-T'as fait
tes exercices de respiration ?
-Non.
Ca va aller.
Franchement, je stresse pas.
-Je pense que ça sera bon.
-Le jury
vous invite
à rentrer dans la salle.
-Bon, les garçons, c'est à nous.
Allez.
Riwan, et après, ce sera Mohamed.
-Vous vous installez,
vous avez tout ce qu'il vous faut.
-Tu as une clé ?
Vas-y, tu t'installes.
-Et là, vous êtes en train
de vous visualiser face aux jurés.
Ce jury est bienveillant.
Ce jury ne peut pas vous regarder
tout le temps
parce qu'il doit prendre des notes.
Vous êtes chronométré :
5 minutes d'oral.
Et vous vous lancez.
-Quand tu démarres,
on démarre.
-Bonjour,
je vais vous présenter mon stage
chez Pentasonic,
qui est une ESN,
c'est une entreprise
de services numériques.
-Bonjour à tous.
Je m'appelle Mohamed
et je vais vous présenter mon oral
sur l'entreprise Ateme.
Donc Ateme est une entreprise basée
dans le traitement de vidéos
pour des clients tels que TF1,
la BBC, Orange, etc.
-D'accord.
-Donc nous sommes allés
au CDAS de Guichen
pour changer un ordinateur
qui ventilait trop.
-Le produit TITAN
va simplement encoder
et compacter un maximum
la vidéo pour entièrement
la faire passer dans un flux
de 24 bits/seconde.
-Le 3e jour,
avec l'aide du technicien,
j'ai changé un écran
sur un PC portable
car la dalle était fissurée.
-Lors de mon stage,
on a pu rencontrer
le poste de PO,
donc Product Owners,
qui est tout simplement
le représentant d'un produit.
-J'ai bien aimé
mes 3 jours de stage,
c'était assez instructif.
-Et ils ont été très gentils,
du coup, je tenais
à remercier l'entreprise
de m'avoir accueilli.
Merci beaucoup, j'ai terminé.
-Des questions ?
-Du coup par rapport
à ton projet personnel,
ça s'inscrit bien
dans ton parcours ?
-Ca m'a bien ouvert la voie
puisque que j'étais assez réticent.
Je pense qu' il y a trop de choses
que je veux faire.
Je voudrais vraiment
me spécialiser dans l'anglais
et les matières
telles que la SVT,
peut-être dans la médecine.
-Tu voudrais allier tout ça ?
-Je sais que c'est compliqué.
-C'est pas du tout
compliqué à réaliser.
Tout ce que tu viens de dire
est totalement réalisable
et on t'y encourage, d'ailleurs.
-D'accord. Merci.
-Bah, bien.
Merci.
-Moi franchement,
je voudrais un travail
qui me plaise.
Et après,
je fais d'autres choses derrière.
-En face de ton nom,
tu signes.
-Il faut bien gagner sa vie
pour pouvoir payer
de quoi se loger,
se nourrir.
-Mohamed, vas-y.
-D'un côté,
c'est un travail,
donc ça doit quand même
avoir une certaine place
dans la vie,
mais est-ce que pour autant
ça devrait me drainer
toute mon énergie ?
J'espère pas.
-En fait, ça serait
d'avoir les deux en même temps,
avoir une famille, des enfants,
avec une situation aisée
et un boulot dans lequel
je suis épanoui
et où je me plais.
Voilà.
-Merci, les garçons ! Bonne journée.
-Merci à vous.
Musique dynamique
-Moi, j'ai envie d'avoir un travail
où je me sens bien.
Pas forcément où je me lève le matin
en disant :
"Yes, une bonne journée
dans mon travail !"
-C'est pas tous les jours comme ça.
-Un métier
où je survis, quoi.
Je ferai jamais ce sacrifice.
J'empilerai pas les cadavres
pour avoir le métier de mes rêves.
Enfin...
-Non, mais c'est clair.
-Mais tu penses que le stage
que t'as fait,
ça t'a un peu motivé
pour travailler ou pas encore ?
-Travailler en cours ?
-Ouais, oui, réussir en cours.
Après, c'est dur tous les jours.
Je sais bien.
-Moi, oui.
Ca m'a motivée pour faire
un bac techno STMG,
Sciences et technologies
du management et de la gestion.
Ca m'intéresse.
-Je pense que ça peut
te correspondre.
Par rapport à ce que tu aimerais
faire plus tard,
tu parlais plus de marketing,
de communication, publicité...
T'apprends ça,
y a quand même des cours spécifiques
et aussi pour faire de la gestion
en entreprise
ou des ressources humaines,
c'est pas complètement anodin.
-Faut bien se renseigner sur ça.
Ouais, ça peut être intéressant.
-Par contre, il va falloir
qu'on réfléchisse aussi
sur les lycées qui proposent
cette filière technologique.
-Ouais, et du coup,
il y en a beaucoup.
Brétigny, Jeanne-d'Arc,
Jean-Macé, Joliot-Curie,
lycée René-Descartes.
-Pourquoi tu peux pas aller
à Chateau ?
-Parce que.
-Si tu veux aller à Chateau,
c'est pour faire une bonne générale,
faut avoir un niveau hyper bon,
si tu veux faire que du général.
Moi, si je vais à Chateau
et que je fais...
Déjà, je veux pas faire de général,
j'ai envie de m'orienter direct.
J'ai envie de faire
quelque chose de concret.
-Tu veux sentir un métier.
-Voilà, exactement.
-Chateaubriand, ça a une réputation
d'être hyper exigeant
et à l'entrée en seconde,
ils poussent quand même les élèves
à se dépasser,
ils mettent la pression.
-Moi j'ai du mal avec les cours.
Faut pas que je craque.
Mais franchement,
si on stresse comme ça,
ma santé mentale part en couille.
Vraiment...
-Bah t'as raison.
-En fait, moi, maintenant,
psychologiquement parlant,
faut que je fasse très attention.
Genre, je dis ça honnêtement,
J'ai besoin d'équilibre,
sinon je peux péter un câble.
Moi, je veux
des choses simples.
Musique douce
...
Moi, la pression...
J'ai envie de faire ça
en mode chill, tu vois.
Genre aller en cours, travailler
et voilà, rentrer chez soi.
Moi, j'ai envie de profiter
de ma jeunesse,
d'une certaine manière,
de pas trop penser au travail,
que les notes n'aient pas
une emprise sur moi.
La classe à l'Assomption,
c'est la meilleure classe
que j'ai eue du collège.
Il y a plus de respect.
Je suis plus sereine en cours.
T'as continué à réviser
pour le brevet blanc ?
Plus que 8 jours !
J'ai beaucoup de traumatismes
de quand j'étais aux Gayeulles.
Par exemple, j'ai beaucoup de mal
en sport.
Le sport aux Gayeulles,
je le vivais comme si
j'étais inférieure, en fait.
Comme si j'étais un animal.
-Donc on a un groupe :
Maximilien, Vianela,
Amaury, Maïté,
Thomas, et un groupe
Paul, Lilou, Camille et Félix.
C'est parti.
-Je savais pas comment
je pouvais y remédier.
"Pourquoi je suis inférieure ?"
-Je sers et c'est à toi.
Tu commences.
-Et c'est vrai que maintenant,
je rate un truc,
y a une personne
qui fait
"Oh mais non, t'abuses",
je le prends hyper à coeur
et j'arrive plus à respirer.
La personne
remarque tout de suite
et dit qu'elle est désolée.
-On va y arriver !
-La première fois,
j'ai trouvé ça surprenant.
"Mais c'est un rêve ?"
Ca existe vraiment,
les personnes qui se rendent compte
du mal qu'elles font ?
Mais si, en fait.
-On te fait confiance.
-Allez, c'est la bonne.
C'est la bonne.
-Bien joué !
Ca, c'est bien, ça !
Voilà !
-J'ai tellement eu
de situations injustes en me disant
que c'est moi le problème,
alors que la situation,
c'est clairement du harcèlement.
C'était une période très sombre.
-Moi, si je veux,
je peux tryhard comme Lilou.
Parce que c'était très propre.
-Merci !
J'ai eu des idées noires,
j'allais souvent aux toilettes
pour pleurer.
Merci. Bien joué.
-Très beau match.
-Pour vous !
J'ai gagné 2 fois de suite,
avec Camille et Daniel.
-C'est bien.
Chaque seconde, je me demandais
comment survivre les 10 prochaines.
C'est comme ça
que j'avançais dans la journée.
Mais pensais juste
à rentrer chez moi.
Quand je partais en cours,
sur le chemin,
dans le bus
ou sur le chemin de l'école,
j'étais en mode
"Tu survis".
Ca s'effacera jamais, ces souvenirs.
J'aurais bien aimé
avoir une adolescence
plus simple,
mais j'ai survécu
et je suis contente
d'être encore là.
Musique douce
...
-C'est toi, Lilou ?
-Bah oui, c'est moi.
-Je t'ai retrouvée sur Insta
mais j'avais oublié de m'abonner
parce que j'étais pas sûre.
-Tu peux ajouter. Ca me dérange pas.
Tu pourras t'abonner au mien ?
-T'inquiète.
-Ca va, en ce moment ?
-Ouais, ça va.
C'est plus facile
de se faire des amis
par le biais des réseaux sociaux.
J'ai du mal à parler aux gens
donc c'est un raccourci
pour parler avec les gens
qu'on voit à l'Assomption.
Tous les amis que j'ai maintenant,
c'est grâce aux réseaux sociaux.
Sans les réseaux sociaux,
on aurait une vie différente.
Alors, moi,
j'ai Instagram.
-Instagram.
-J'ai Snapchat.
-SNAPCHAT.
-Et...
-TIKTOK.
-J'en ai pas
et j'en aurai pas de sitôt.
Je sais pas
si j'aurais le droit,
je sais pas si j'en aurais envie
non plus.
De toute façon,
j'ai pas de téléphone, donc...
-Des fois, je poste des stories
de ce que je fais
juste pour avoir un aperçu
un peu de ma vie en général.
-En ce moment,
un des sujets qui m'intéressent,
c'est le airsoft.
Ca c'est du airsoft.
-Je regarde
presque tout sur Instagram,
qui font des trucs humoristiques.
-Je sais même pas
comment ça marche. Je sais pas.
J'ai un ordi, ça me suffit.
Je regarde des matchs de basket.
Musique intrigante
...
-Je suis pas beaucoup
d'influenceurs,
je suis des chanteurs.
Je suis Britney Spears, Lil Peep,
Billie Eilish, Selena Gomez,
Taylor Swift, Orelsan,
Lomepal...
Après, les chanteurs sont
un peu influenceurs.
-Les influenceurs t'influencent ?
-J'ai envie de dire non.
-Non, ça m'influence pas.
-J'irai pas jusque là
parce que je réfléchis un minimum
avant de me dire
"Ah, ce produit, il est mieux."
...
-C'est pas parce qu'un influenceur
veut vendre des baskets
que je vais les acheter.
-C'est les publicités d'aujourd'hui
parce que la personne,
tu peux lui faire confiance,
parce que tu vois
ses vidéos souvent.
*-Si tu veux devenir beau gosse,
c'est pas de la muscu
"qu'il faut que tu fasses
mais de la chirurgie esthétique."
-LOL !
C'est une approche très pote à pote.
Quand je vois des influenceurs,
je me dis que c'est la vie parfaite.
Ils partent en vacances,
ils vont faire du surf à Los Angeles
mais t'en sais rien, ils montrent
que ce qu'ils ont envie de montrer.
Musique dynamique
...
-On voit beaucoup
sur les réseaux sociaux
de gens qui ont
un physique incroyable,
qui sont musclés, beaux,
qui ont confiance.
Et donc tu te dis à toi-même
"Il faut que je ressemble à ça".
Je culpabilisais énormément
après.
En gros, depuis plusieurs années,
je ne suis pas à l'aise
avec mon corps.
...
Je voyais beaucoup de choses
sur les réseaux,
de gens qui parlaient
de comment perdre du poids,
des recettes saines,
des recettes...
Des recettes perte de poids
ou des choses comme ça.
Donc, j'ai vu énormément
d'informations,
et j'en ai ressorti une chose,
de ce trop-plein d'informations,
c'est que pour perdre du poids
ou de la masse grasse,
il fallait être
en déficit calorique.
*-1 : Pour ne pas stimuler
l'insuline,
réduisez le sucre,
mais également les féculents.
*2 : Ne mangez pas trop souvent.
Ne broutez pas toute la journée
comme des vaches.
Même prolongez
votre jeune nocturne de 12 heures
à 13, 14, 15, 16 heures,
pour moins stimuler l'insuline.
*Dites-moi en commentaires
si ça vous a aidé.
Musique douce
-Je me suis mise
à faire hyper attention
à tout ce que je mangeais
et je me suis mise à éviter
les calories au maximum,
donc j'ai changé
toute mon alimentation.
Comme j'ai essayé d'éviter
au maximum les calories,
je me suis mis à compter
tout ce que je mangeais.
On va au frais.
Il nous reste du concombre ?
-Non, pas beaucoup.
Tu peux en reprendre.
Je te laisse prendre les bananes ?
-Ouais.
J'ai essayé beaucoup
de recettes...
"saines",
donc, c'est-à-dire on remplace...
On remplace le sucre
par la banane,
ou des trucs sans beurre,
sans sucre, tout ça...
Musique sombre
...
*"Somebody That I Used To Know",
Gotye
*...
Je fais une salade...
basique.
Je veux avoir
le moins de calories possible.
*...
Au début,
je mettais des féculents,
et puis, comme j'ai vu
que les féculents,
c'était quand même beaucoup plus
calorique que de la salade,
j'ai changé le riz complet
pour de la salade.
Ma mère me l'avait déjà dit
plusieurs fois,
qu'il fallait
que je mette des féculents
dans mes salades le midi.
Je l'ai pas écoutée
parce que sur les réseaux,
j'avais vu tellement
d'informations contradictoires
que pour moi,
le seul conseil valable
aurait été celui
d'un professionnel de santé,
quelqu'un qui me dit :
"Tu mets ta santé en danger
si tu fais pas ça."
Musique douce
-Let's go !
-C'est vrai qu'en matière
d'infos contradictoires,
entre les réseaux sociaux
et les appels à la malbouffe
dans les rues de Manchester,
il y a de quoi se perdre.
...
-Là, on peut y aller !
Gauche, droite,
ou tout droit et gauche.
-Tout droit et gauche.
Si j'ai trouvé où on va...
-Exactement !
C'est dans ce bâtiment-là,
à droite.
-C'est là ?
-Ouais. On va dedans ?
-En Angleterre,
y a pas mal de restaurants
qui mettent les calories
sur le menu.
Donc ça,
ça m'aidait pas mal.
Du coup,
je prenais souvent
le plat le moins calorique.
-Bon, tout le monde
est content de son choix ?
-Ouais.
-C'est grave bon.
Par contre, c'est salé un max.
-Des calories,
Coline en a quand même
brûlé pas mal,
à découvrir l'Angleterre.
Cliché d'appareil photo
Musique rock
...
-Bon, alors,
le bilan de l'année ?
-C'était une bonne expérience,
mais j'ai pas aimé.
-Une bonne expérience
que t'as pas aimée ?
-Oui.
-Une bonne expérience en quoi ?
-J'ai appris plein de trucs.
J'ai un bon niveau d'anglais.
Même sans parler
juste de l'anglais, les maths,
ils ont un niveau supérieur,
les sciences, aussi.
Donc j'ai un meilleur niveau
en sciences et en maths.
-Ready ? Let's go !
-Le volley,
c'est beaucoup mieux.
Je fais deux fois par semaine
du volley.
Je préfère le volley ici
qu'en France.
Elle crie en anglais.
Enfin, je me sens un peu plus
en confiance ici.
Je trouve que le groupe,
il est mieux.
Je me sens un peu plus incluse.
Propos en anglais
Musique douce
...
J'ai appris que quand même,
les Anglais et les Français,
même s'il y a 500 km d'écart,
ils sont pas du tout pareil.
Ils ont pas les mêmes moyens
de fonctionner,
que ce soit pour la scolarité,
ou même, en dehors de ça,
dans la vie de tous les jours.
Je pensais que ça allait être cool,
que j'allais me faire des potes,
que ça allait aller vite
et que ça allait être vraiment
une super expérience.
Au final, je pense
que je m'attendais à beaucoup,
et du coup,
j'ai été super déçue,
par le fait de, notamment,
de pas avoir de potes,
par le fait de l'école,
aussi,
parce que je pensais
qu'ils allaient faire
un peu plus attention...
Les profs,
ils font pas forcément
attention à toi.
Elle tape sur son clavier.
*Musique d'attente Skype
*...
Allez !
*-Ouais !
-Oh, t'es là !
Ah, coucou.
Ca va ?
*-Ouais, et toi ?
-Oui, j'ai repris les cours
aujourd'hui.
J'étais en vacances
en Ecosse, c'était cool.
J'ai repris aujourd'hui.
Je me suis un peu fait chier,
mais ça change pas
de d'habitude.
Toujours toute seule,
pas d'amis, tout ça.
*-Mais t'avais pas dit
que t'avais...
-Ouais, je suis allée voir
un film chez une meuf,
mais je suis juste
allée voir un film...
*-On dirait un début, genre.
-Un début ?
Mais il reste un mois.
Si jamais elles viennent
me reparler, OK,
si elles viennent pas...
je m'en fiche.
*-Ouais, c'est ça.
-Il reste 32 jours.
J'aurais bien voulu
être avec les autres
pour fêter la fin d'année,
le passage au lycée,
ou même ne serait-ce
que pour être
avec les potes, quoi.
Ca aurait pu être cool,
mais...
Si j'étais restée
dans mon collège,
ça aurait été plus simple
niveau brevet.
*-Ton oral,
tu le fais comment ?
-J'ai pas d'oral.
*-Ah ouais ?
-En fait, le brevet,
je vais pas dire
que j'ai pas révisé,
mais je vais pas dire
que j'ai révisé de fou non plus.
*-Mais tu peux l'avoir.
-Oui, mais toi,
t'étais en cours,
t'as pu écouter en cours,
alors que moi, non.
Mais je pense
que ça va le faire.
La matière
où je vais le moins gérer,
ça va rester l'histoire géo.
Mais je vais essayer
de me dépatouiller.
En français, pareil.
La rédaction, ça va aussi...
être un peu mon point faible,
mais j'aurai mon brevet.
J'ai pas trop de doutes.
*-Faut que tu révises.
-Bah, ouais.
Passe le bonjour
à tout le monde.
*-Ouais.
-See you, goodbye.
*-A plus !
-Hop !
-Alors, ce matin, histoire,
et cet aprèm,
ce sera SVT-physique.
Ca va bien se passer,
surtout que théoriquement,
il me manque 50 points
pour avoir mon brevet,
donc je me dis que ça va.
-T'as eu des conseils
de ta mère avant de partir ?
-Ben, juste que je pouvais
y arriver, hein.
Musique douce
...
Oh là là là là là là !
Bonjour !
-Ca va, frérot ?
Tu stresses pas trop ?
-Non, au calme.
-Non, ça va ?
-Ah là là...
-Tu fais comment, toi ?
-Au calme, t'inquiète !
Brouhaha
Au calme, tu fais :
introduction,
trois arguments
par paragraphe et...
-Pourquoi il rigole, lui ?
Il a raison !
Il a raison, je crois !
-Bonne chance, les gars !
-Allez, on y va.
-Au calme.
-C'est le brevet, quand même.
-T'as les connaissances.
-Bonne chance, Adam.
-Bon courage.
-Bonne chance, Elliot.
-Bonne chance !
Ca va aller, c'est bon !
No stress.
Musique rythmée douce
...
-Le brevet, nous y voilà.
Les notes de l'année
sont déjà arrêtées,
mais il s'agit tout de même
de ne pas le prendre à la légère.
...
-Notez votre numéro d'épreuve.
La page 9 sera à rendre
avec la copie.
Il faudra nous la donner...
...
-Alors, Riwan,
ce qui me paraît très intéressant,
c'est qu'il est autonome
par rapport à son travail
et il est en très bonne maîtrise
quasiment partout.
C'est bien, c'est solide.
-Riwan,
je le trouve très drôle,
parce qu'il a tout le temps
envie de bien faire,
mais il est pas forcément prêt
à fournir
les efforts pour le faire,
pour atteindre son objectif.
-Un brin de nonchalance.
-Non, mais ça vient
et ça va venir l'année prochaine.
Enfin, c'est clair que...
il grandit beaucoup, quoi.
...
-Mohamed va mieux,
me semble-t-il.
Au deuxième trimestre,
c'était quand même
un petit peu plus délicat.
Il a eu un petit passage à vide,
mais là,
le troisième trimestre
est rassurant,
et en ce qui concerne
l'échange oral,
moi, je le trouve plus présent.
Toi, je ne sais pas
si tu trouves une différence ?
-Oui, ça dépend un peu
de ses humeurs,
mais globalement,
il est quand même bien dedans.
Il a envie de bien faire.
Il a tenté sa chance
et il a essayé de réagir
au bon moment.
-Ouais.
-Maël est autonome,
il sait s'organiser,
il est sérieux,
mais il aurait pu s'investir
un petit peu plus.
Il y a un manque de rigueur
dans certaines matières
parce qu'il veut faire
du dessin,
mais il faudra
qu'il confirme quand même
dans la rédaction
et le raisonnement.
...
Brouhaha
-Au revoir.
-Alors, ça a été ?
-Oui, oui...
Je suis content.
-Franchement facile...
-T'as géré ?
-Oui, j'ai géré.
...
-Quand je dis que 2 heures,
c'est trop long...
-T'as fini
une demi-heure avant ?
-Non, ça fait 15 minutes
déjà, là, que j'ai terminé.
-T'as mis combien de temps ?
-1 heure 15
au lieu de 2 heures.
...
-On a essayé de nous mettre
un peu la pression
pour qu'on travaille, quoi,
mais les épreuves étaient pas
si difficiles que ça.
La mention très bien,
je pense que je l'ai déjà, donc...
-Le premier vrai examen
de leur vie
se termine à peine.
-Ils t'ont mis là où il y avait
de la place, hein !
-Et déjà, un grand stress...
-Je suis en quoi ? En 3D ?
-T'es en 3D, toi !
-Surtout pour Mohamed.
Il espère intégrer
le très réputé
lycée Chateaubriand,
juste à côté,
une voie royale,
pour les études.
-T'es tous tes livres ?
-Oui.
-Tu veux un dossier de bourse
pour l'année prochaine ?
-Oui, je veux bien, merci.
-Mais ce n'est pas
son lycée de secteur.
Rien n'est sûr.
-Et ton affectation.
-Merci beaucoup !
-Son avenir est écrit
sur ce papier.
-Ah, OK, c'est bon !
Merci beaucoup
et bonnes vacances !
-Alors ?
-Je suis accepté à Chateau.
-T'es content ?
-Ouais, ça va.
-T'es accepté ?
-A Chateau, ouais.
-Viens avec moi !
-Ecoute, c'était trop tard !
Ouais, je suis content.
Oh là là là là !
Musique rock
-Alors ?
-Je suis accepté à Chateau.
-Wallah, mon frère !
-Va mettre des couleurs là-bas !
Rires et brouhaha
...
-J'ai fait "waouh" !
-T'es content quand même ?
-Ouais, je suis content.
...
Au revoir, merci beaucoup.
-Au revoir !
-Bonne continuation !
-Tu vas où ?
-A Chateaubriand.
-T'es content ?
-Ouais.
Allez, on y va !
...
-Au revoir !
Tu vas me manquer.
Non, vraiment !
Tu vas me manquer, frère.
-On s'attrapera.
-On s'attrape, on s'attrape.
Tu vas où ?
-Là ! Et toi ?
-Moi, je vais là.
Mohamed rit.
-Espèce de trop intelligent !
Musique rock
Brouhaha et rires
...
-La période du collège
se termine aujourd'hui.
-Au revoir !
...
-AU REVOIR !
-Tu vas me manquer, Mohamed !
-Oh là là !
...
-Une nouvelle époque s'ouvre :
celle du lycée.
Elle reste à écrire.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
...